Alex Rosen:
We are here at Baker Rink and it is Skate
Night tonight. Lets see what's going on.
[music]
Carrie Sweet:
I came by skate night tonight because I heard
everyone's going, I heard it would be a lot
Carrie Sweet:
of fun, and skating is something that I rarely
ever did, and I thought it would be a lot of
Carrie Sweet:
fun to try it again.
[music]
Colin Hanna:
I skated tonight. I did some quick laps. Actually,
I saw some very impressive ballerina type
Colin Hanna:
things. I was impressed with the other
students in the Princeton student body.
Alex Rosen:
You didn't try any of that though?
Colin Hanna:
No, not for me.
[music]
Students:
Why is Skate Night such a good event at Princeton?
Student:
Ugly sweaters.
Good friends.
Student:
And good friends wearing ugly sweaters!
Alex Rosen:
We are here right now with the winner of the
ugly sweater contest. How did you find this sweater?
Erin Mills:
It was in my mother's closet in the back.
Alex Rosen:
So, did you come out more tonight for the
skating or the ugly sweater contest?
Erin Mills:
Well, I love to skate but I definitely knew
that the sweater contest was going on, and
Erin Mills:
when I went home for Thanksgiving break I
brought back this sweater.
Alex Rosen:
So are you a good skater, then?
Erin Mills:
Pretty decent. I own my own pair of skates. I come
from Maine, and it is pretty cold up there,
Erin Mills:
so I have done a lot of skating.
Alex Rosen:
Do you ever fall down anymore?
Erin Mills:
I'm sure I do sometimes when I try to do something
stupid or beyond my abilities.
Colin Hanna:
I fell down once or twice.
Student:
I kind of trip and fall a lot.
[music]
Gary Walters:
What is important here is just the genuine
joy that I see and the smiles on everybody
Gary Walters:
who is participating here.
[music, cheers]
Student:
Skate night was so much fun and all my friends
were here. We came with a student group and
Student:
we all had a really great time. I can't wait
for the next one.
[music]